I'm Marcus Leto I am the creative
director and the president of v1
interactive I have been in the game
industry for almost 24 years now
building games like the Halo franchise
from scratch all the way to where it is
when we left it with Bungie and now
building a new studio v1 interactive and
I'm really excited about what we've
built together with desintegration our
debut title my career actually started
off in graphic design took a while to to
get my foot in the door but eventually I
did Bungie was real small at that time
and it was at that time that I just
started working with Jason Jones of
Bungie and the two of us began riffing
on game ideas at that time and it
ultimately turned into the very initial
seeds of what became halo we had no idea
whether or not we were going to build a
successful game at all we liked what we
were making but would it be popular who
knew we weren't sure that has just of
course that was a crazy rollercoaster
ride of making awesome fun games or some
of them were really hard to make but
they were always very fulfilling and
while I was there I think we got up to
the 300 person range the only thing I
didn't like about it really is that I
becomes less personal and it was towards
the end of that process where budgee had
grown to the immense size that I decided
to just kind of pull back from that a
little bit and decide to change gears
and maybe try something new and wanted
to maybe consider building a new studio
from scratch so I can get back to the
roots of doing something really fun with
a small team where everybody's hands-on
and critical path leaving Bungie I
wasn't exactly sure what I was going to
work on I explored several different
ideas
little little teeny mobile game ideas
two large triple-a game ideas it was
pretty easy for me to pivot right at
that point and say I'm going to start my
new studio we want interactive I've got
a game cookin that I was kind of
interested in a game fiction actually
the same and I think I could build a
viable prototype around that that
fiction and so as we continue to explore
the prototype we're rebuilding we did
change the tide quite a few times and we
decided to mix these two things though
part FPS a little bit of RTS and explore
how those territories could actually
clay nice together and really do shake
things up to the point where it creates
and carves out a niche all by itself in
the genres of game it was actually
rather serendipitous one of my my key
employees now his name's Joe Arroyo he's
now the technical design director of the
studio we chatted for a while over beers
and had a good time talking about video
games but that was it when he went back
to school and then one day I was like I
really do need someone to help me work
on building a prototype so I'm like I
know the perfect person this guy Joe so
he and his friend Nick ghoulish and then
joined me and we spent about two years
building the prototype so it took quite
a long time but I didn't want to rush it
we wanted to make sure we took our time
to get those core fundamental parts
right one of the key elements and the
first things that I dope into with
disintegration was what are these
characters what are the reason for them
existing in this world that I'm trying
to cook up here and what should they
look like how should they function I
didn't want to like build like character
archetypes and start writing dialogue
for anybody at that point because it was
way too soon to start thinking about
that it was really just a point to look
at what would be like really interesting
and cool character and - I specifically
like for this one particular image with
the pilot variants because one of the
key
of our game is that we have human
characters human people that have
actually transferred the brain into an
armored shell and attached that to a
robotic armature and so it was critical
that they as humans they bring along
some of those affectations of who they
used to be as human like some of the
clothing elements that they wear or how
they adorn themselves with chains or or
paint themselves like with graffiti
that's kind of like tattoos over their
bodies I'm a big believer in form
follows function and that making sure
that that they actually looked
believable in the first place was also a
really big drive so initially I wanted
to you know start building ships and
other kind of cool stuff that I was used
to kind of constructing or designing
from the Halo universe but the world
that I had built for disintegration
wasn't a big militarized world it wasn't
all about characters like spark ins and
warthogs and tanks and that kind of
stuff so it really freed me from
pigeonholing myself into redoing that
kind of an environment or competing with
that in any way building the world for
disintegration that was another big
challenge because it's it's all set on
earth what I wanted to do then was play
around with design ideas and motifs that
are all very familiar to the player and
also to set up a world that is a
beautiful place to explore like this is
not a post-apocalyptic nuclear
burned-out world this is a world where
humanity just cease to exist in great
numbers and so nature took over pretty
quick it looks pretty clunky and it kind
of is but it was literally that just a
prototype at this time and it was a
spiritual successor to some of the thing
that game that I loved the most my first
interaction at Bungie we're building
myth the Fallen Lords which is a
real-time tactical game I really wanted
to do something similar to that I think
we got pretty far with it to the point
where if we looked
we're like yeah that's pretty cool I
like that but you know if it's gonna
stand out if it's gonna have one chance
in hell of standing out in the sea of
other games like this it's we got to do
something very different here it was at
that point it was right during this
construction of our construction phase
of the project that I said I've gotta
flip the table here we've got to try
something completely different and
that's when it was like one I literally
were like one of those
middle-of-the-night things where you're
like oh I think I know what we can do I
think this might actually work and I
proposed the idea and while there was
initially a lot of resistance to the
idea of thinking that it's just gonna
turn it into another action game turned
it into another shoe room but as soon as
we got something functional and we
started flying that ship around in the
sky and we started commanding those
ground units in at the same time like
something magical happened there I think
we all recognized at that point that
this is gonna be something that's gonna
catch the attention of people in a way
that I think will get them excited
leading up to the technical beta that
was earlier in the year I was pretty
convinced myself that we were we were
not ready and that things were more
gonna explode gloriously and that that
was going to be the end of our game and
that no one was gonna talk about it from
that point forward literally our goal
was to try to break the game in any way
possible so I guess I wouldn't have been
surprised had it exploded but but it
held together and we really stressed had
to stress tested the crap out of it and
and had a good time playing it as a
result it was it turned out to be a
really positive thing for us and we got
a ton of great feedback from it too and
so we took all that part and continued
to evolve the game beyond that well up
until I mean just a few weeks ago as we
wrapped up the game during a pandemic
the some of that is actually then the
you know the crux of where innovation
comes from when you just are trying
things over and over again
and iterating on something and you just
come across happy accidents like that
that turn into a real feature but
oftentimes it's just weird stuff that
happens in making games and sometimes
they're hilarious to look at and we try
to capture some of those moments every
now and then because when they get us
laughing hysterically at the office
we'll burn something like that happens
and go back and look at some of the some
of the old concept some of the old
builds play some of the old builds that
we had made quite some time ago and it's
it's a humbling experience to look
through what we where we started and how
we've really changed this game
dramatically over the time I'm real
excited and happy about what I see every
time I played through some of these
older builds because I it's a it's an
opportunity to reflect back on where we
were at at that time and what problems
we had yet discovered solutions for that
we're still persistent in some of those
old builds and to really kind of look at
that fondly and at this point now it's
easier to do that where I can I can look
back at that and I say at that time I
wasn't sure whether or not we would be
able to find solutions for some of these
problems I'm real proud of the studio
for what we were able to do together so
when it came to our first announce back
at Gamescom last year in Germany
boy that was nerve-racking oh my god
that was awesome though it was such a
great experience to see that and get
excited and amped about that that whole
you know experience of it all finally
coming together and seeing people
actually play the game together
that was fantastic if I were to go back
in time to talk to myself I think I
would just I would let myself know that
I have to be patient this is something
that I've always carried through all my
life this is good things only happen
when you really work hard at it
after leaving Bungie I it's not like I
expected something to happen immediately
but there was this ant
dissipation that was really eating at me
and if I can't go back in time and just
tell myself calm down it'll happen just
take your time and take a nice deep
breath and enjoy this moment because it
is really a great time just reflect on
where you're gonna go with your career
and what you can do next
and just get your stuff together and and
march forward
[Music]